can we talk about poker ah no because I
want the audience noble enough people
I've seen bored yeah it's one of those
shows where it's not the best sure but
it's a very important one that I think
people should watch yeah and I don't
know how to describe that's very
eloquently disturbing but not for like
the conventional reason for it being
disturbed yeah
so what boy chrono is about is there's
this group of kids there's go some
awesome by the way even Gillian Ripley
Veronica because there's these group of
kids and then the like the I think
they're on this school trip or something
spin a while school trip yeah and then
they find this all I remember is they
find his cave with a talking head or
something like that so there's a guy in
a cave and he's like a middle-aged man
working on like a PC and right it's
really weird Sarah yeah and he basically
asked them do you want to play a game
would you like to play a game which you
know anyone asking you that ever with a
bunch of kids in immediate no and then I
think they all get on the scale or
something they all turns he measures
them and then you know they whatever
happens and suddenly they go outside or
happens later on in that evening because
they're all we've kitchen no these
characters a little bit that's like how
many kids is there 12 like 12 30 years
something like that around that many
kids and then they get teleported into
this huge Mac and there's a scary
floating head that's like talking to
them and and one of the children asks to
pilot the mech and now we're gonna go
into spoil this a little bit but yeah
it's it's episode one so I'm gonna spoil
the premise a little bit to you but yeah
so one of the kids pilots the mech and
they're fighting another Mac and it's to
save the world then they're told
yes floating head character very
intimidating character so they win the
battle hurray they all win they all
celebrate and they go outside they stand
on the Mac and then one of the kids just
drops dead and falls off the Mac then
they find out that each time this mech
comes back and they're summoned one of
the kids has to pilot the mech and when
they do they're gonna die immediately
after yeah Bart it's to save the world
yeah and what the the real beauty of
this show
isn't really the mech battles or the
mech fights it's more of the fact that
these kids who have to pilot the mech to
save the world like every is like it's
kept basically kind of like a monster of
the week on a show right yeah every week
a new monster comes along and the new
kids another kid from that group has to
pilot the mech
it's about the backstory of each of the
kids and just having to deal with the
fact that they're gonna die yes they're
just gonna die and in like really
realistic ways as well like these
characters are very believable it makes
me like uncomfortable even like thinking
back to like the emotions that poured
out and me yeah they're like I get like
very like it's really really brutally
honest look into like the human
condition and yeah life and especially
how its you know a lot of these kids
from a lot of different backgrounds some
of them have it easier I remember
there's a one kid who's the
stereotypical piece of [ __ ] but there's
some of the kids you know who I think
there's one kid who's like 16 or
whatever nice looking after two is two
siblings
yeah and it's brutal because this he's
the one who's raising these two his two
sisters I think yeah and it's horrible
seeing him after like come to terms with
that he's not gonna better look after
his sister it's rude it's something that
just disturbs you want to like a level
that you can't really do it's so raw
it's so realistic yeah you know filters
yeah whatsoever I'm like it's it's
something that already was like not many
people have watched it's it's something
I was really good uncomfortable it's
really uncomfortable have to like sit
down and sit through I I admit I
definitely like did not watch it when I
was first came out like I definitely
gave us some time yo cuz I cuz I think
the problem with boquerón on the reason
why so many people didn't watch it when
it came I was because the way that they
marketed it was not that good not that
anger like oh it's a makeup must just be
like yelling rip off there's no world
where it's like the number one anime
because it's just too uncomfortable yeah